Oh, can we figure it out?
How's it going, dude?
Good man, sit home with my puppy, watch him tear shit up like he does.
Besides that, day off.
So we do like a Kelly, I think it's called, where we have a four day break.
And I took a day off on the last day.
So I'm on six days, which is real nice.
Oh, nice.
Got anything fun planned?
Well, this time, no, my girl was out of town.
So I had to bring the puppy with me to the station.
In the first two days, it was fine.
But it kind of got a lot, you know, a rather busy service.
Not like, you know, 20 calls in a day busy, but like, we'll easily get 10 or the
course of 24, like bad nights would be like maybe like 15 in a day.
And it's a lot for one day.
It's good experience, though, you know?
Yeah, for sure.
Yeah.
When I first started, I was working on a, like a private service right outside of
Pittsburgh and we ran a lot as well.
It seems nuts now to think about it.
Cause for us, like, you know, three flights in a day is a lot, but we used to do like
10 runs, no problem.
No, just, yeah.
That's how it was.
Yeah.
But then you get the pressure on you though, with just a single flight, you know?
It just definitely takes a lot longer with like charting and it's a lot of, yeah.
A lot of, a lot of time.
Whereas I run for pretty short.
Do you guys like a few land and like a patient needs innovated, will you
innovate them where they are?
And then like, like pretty much have them ready to go by the time you're ready to
fly.
Yeah.
We, we try and do everything on the ground.
At least where I work every now and again, we'll get in a situation where we're
trying to manage airway, like in route, but we definitely prefer to do it on the
ground, especially because most of the bases in this region are pretty small
helicopters.
We fly in eight stars.
So there's not a lot of room to do stuff once you get up in the air.
Yeah.
Seems sketchy, man.
That's not that bad.
You like flying in general.
I do.
Yeah.
I've tried to leave a couple of times, but I keep coming back.
Well, that's good, man.
You found your niche, you know?
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah.
I didn't know if you want to just dive into your, your notes you sent over and we
can just kind of run down that checklist like we did before.
And everything I had on here, even if it doesn't have a question mark, most of it
is kind of like, I know a lot of them are just questions in like their context, but
so like the first one that I'll be roll for hyperklemia.
I don't like our protocols.
We don't have this in there.
But I had a doctor that I respect.
He told me that you can use Albuterol to get serum potassium into the actual cell
itself.
And so I was thinking on it and what did you kind of like because with hyperklemia,
the big worry that we have is the rate of cardia.
And of course it going into like a terminal sine wave or something.
But what have you ever seen it done?
Have you ever used it?
Kind of what are your thoughts on it?
Yeah, the only time like we, we do use Albuterol for like a hyperklemia protocol.
I don't know if I've ever done it in the field, but we do that sometimes in the
hospital if we have someone who is hyperkalemic and you know, there's decent
evidence that it works.
But it's like part of an overall strategy.
So we're not just doing that.
We're doing like a whole sequence of things to, to both shift the potassium
back into the cells and also to get rid of some of the potassium that's in the
rid of some of the potassium.
So yeah, it's like one of the components of that.
The only time you really see it mentioned in the pre-hospital setting is with
crush injury.
Yeah.
So if you had somebody who was like stuck under whatever for a long period of time,
ideally you would, you know, have access to everything.
So if it was an extremity, you know, put a turn and get on the extremity.
When the, when the object gets released, we're worried about the influx of all that
like tissue and the contents of the tissue that broke down, getting back into
circulation.
Ideally the tourniquet would solve that problem, but if you still had some of
that stuff get into the body, you have two primary concerns.
One is like going into a acute renal failure because you have that myoglobin
release in the bloodstream.
And the other is the hyperkalemia with the potassium influx.
So specific to the hyper potassium, I'm sorry, hyperkalemia, the high potassium
that are normal, like treatment in a hospital setting.
We would do the albuterol if we're concerned about any arrhythmia, then we
would give calcium to stabilize the cardiac tissue itself.
And then we also will give insulin and dextrose.
So giving insulin will shift the potassium into the cells in a similar
manner to the way albuterol works.
But then you're at risk for the patient becoming hyperglycemic.
So then we give dextrose as well.
And then to get rid of, like to get potassium actually out of the body, not
just to cause a shift, then we give Kexilate.
But in the field, like we don't really have this option.
So you're basically limited to like in the context of a crush injury, you can
do the tourniquet thing and then you can do albuterol like most of us aren't
using, most of us don't have insulin in the field, so our options are limited
in the field, so that's when you might see it.
Yeah, I saw with the insulin, like obviously we don't have it, right?
We're just a standard like fire service.
But I was reading, I believe it was the calcium channel blocker and beta blocker
MCRIT, or maybe it's like the Internet Book of Critical Care, but they had
insulin in theirs as well.
And they were saying do the same thing because when you give the insulin, you
got to worry about the hypo and give that and then you're just kind of balancing
the two amongst one another.
Yeah.
And like, I don't know of any programs that like carry insulin in the field.
That's mostly a hospital thing, but yeah, that's definitely the idea behind it.
Um, that said, I don't know about using it as like a, an agent specifically for
bradycardia, I think if you were worried about a patient going into a lethal
arrhythmia with high potassium, like calcium will be your fix for that.
Maybe not your fixed, but it'll, it'll prevent that lethal arrhythmia hopefully.
Sweet.
That one's covered.
The second one.
Um, so like this is going more with the hyperclemia.
So if you have your patients that, and the only, the only hyperclemic patient
I've ever had was pretty severe bradycardia and we picked them up from their
house, they had skipped however many days.
But if you have that patient that's kind of on the in between, um, they're not
very bradycardic, but maybe they have like their hyper acute T waves.
Um, would you leave them alone if they're asymptomatic or would you give them that
calcium because you know that they're going to end up needing it anyway?
Yeah.
So if I'm worried about them going into a lethal arrhythmia, I will give the calcium
generally in a, in a hospital setting.
Um, or if you're working with a program that I can draw labs in the field, we
base that on a serum potassium, but like most of us don't have that.
So if I'm worried about it, like, man, this guy does not look good.
And I'm more than they're, they're going to deteriorate and you have it's totally
okay to go ahead and get that calcium.
Sweet.
And then I noticed we have sodium bicarb and our protocols for the hyperclemia.
I would assume this is because whoever's writing the protocols, assuming
that they have renal disease and then therefore they have metabolic acidosis
or does the sodium bicarb help directly with.
The hyperclemia.
So the sodium bicarb doesn't help directly with the hyperclemia.
But if you, if you start to fix the metabolic acidosis, then you will get
a shift of potassium back into the cells.
So when you, when you are, when you're in a state of acidosis, um, your
cells lose potassium into the, into the bloodstream.
So that's when you see the alveolar potassium and you're at risk for having
that arrhythmia.
So whatever you can do to either directly move that potassium back in the cells
or fix the acidosis, um, like what will address the problem.
Um, you don't often see, um, you mentioned that like you never see sodium
bicarbonate in a DKA protocol.
Um, there's not a lot of great evidence about like sodium bicarb in general
for metabolic acidosis.
Um, if you, yeah, I mean, you still see it given like fairly often, like kind
of has like last ditch effort, be like, Oh man, my patient's super sick.
I don't really know what to do.
So let's give bicarb.
Um, if you are going to do that, um, the preferred method would be to do it
like a slow drip versus like slamming it.
Cause if you slam it, um, it either has no effect or can potentially make things worse.
Um, but I don't think I was, I was trying to find an article.
Um, let me see if I still have pulled up about this specifically, um, bicarb in,
uh, DKA, uh, I know that we like almost never see it, but I wasn't sure if there
was like specific stuff on it and I did come across something.
Let me see if I can pull it up here.
Um, yeah, there was an article, I'll send you a link that was just in
general about bicarbonate in patients with metabolic acidosis in general.
Um, so it kind of like goes through just the, you know, the overview of everything,
but it also talks about like specific ideologies, whether it's like, uh,
lactic acidosis, septic shock, DKA.
Um, and it specifically talks about DKA and that there's, you know, the
evidence just isn't there to support its use.
So, but I'll, I'll send you a link to that and whatever else we come up with on the way.
In your opinion, do you feel like sodium bicarb is kind of something that,
uh, EMS is really hanging onto because it seems like it's been around a while and
everybody knows now you can't push it in codes and expect it to work at all.
Yeah.
And it's not just an EMS, like you see it in the hospital too.
Like, I mean, we always, the cliche example is like, all right, you're
working a code and you get like four or five rounds in and then you're like,
all right, what, what are we missing?
I don't know.
Let's give bicarb.
Right.
And you see that in the hospital too.
It's not specific to EMS.
Um, I think eventually that'll fall out of favor.
Um, but there's like a lot of, like folks tend to hold onto something that like
gives them a chance of hope.
Like in that situation, like you're pretty much out of options.
So like, well, it's probably not going to hurt.
It's definitely not going to fix anything, but it's probably not going to hurt.
And the theory behind it is that, you know, like it can fix in, if you, if
you give it correctly, like it can help.
It's like one, one tool in your tool bag to like fix acidosis.
Um, so that's kind of the idea behind it.
But the way we give it as a push those in cardiac arrest is just not effective.
So I think eventually we'll see people stop doing that.
But for now, for now it's there.
Like it for a like asthma or aspirin overdoses.
I had a lady that tried to kill herself.
She took it on a gobbly amount, like a Sam's club bottle worth of
aspirin, and they ended up putting her on a grid in the ICU.
Yeah.
We'll see that sometimes with overdoses where we're like having one of
bicard drip, like, like slow and steady for quite a long period of time
in cases like that.
Um, and in that situation, until they make sense.
Um, yeah, I think most often I see in the hospital with overdoses, like when
you have poison control, getting you specific guidance on the case.
Okay.
I think that covers all the hyper kit ones.
Uh, so number three, the calcium for the PEA.
I was listening to, uh, I think it's two 57 on impret and it's a episode
specifically about PEA and kind of talking how it's, uh, there should be
like a deviation and like, is there contractions that's not generating a
pulse because it's not strong enough or is this a true PEA with no
cardiac contractions?
Now I know in the field, there's no, we don't have echoes, at least we don't.
So there's no way we're down the heart and see if there is a
contraction in the first place.
Um, but you know, like, let's say you have your tube, your compressions
are going well, right?
You're kind of hitting that point that we just talked about where
people are like, okay, you know, what are we missing?
I know they say push it for any dialysis patients because you should assume
hypercase that they may kind of took them down, but I couldn't find any
really bad adverse effects of pushing calcium in the case of a PEA.
Yeah.
There was actually a podcast just recently.
Um, it's called EM cases and it was episode 169.
Um, it's like the most recent one I listened to, but they were just reviewing,
like they were doing an update on like changes in practice for cardiac
arrest in general, and they specifically talked about, um, calcium.
And they kind of had the same idea is that, um, if you can't make that distinction,
like it may be the case that it's just a contraction that is not strong enough to
perfuse and in that situation, like giving calcium might make sense.
Um, most of that data collection is like in the hospital setting where you have
access to echo, so you could like make that determination pretty easy.
Um, or, you know, bedside ultrasound.
Um, in our situation in the field, I think that makes sense.
Like if you, if you had a PA arrest and you weren't sure, um, yeah, I mean,
it's not going to hurt.
Um, the data is not there, but again, the data is skewed because it's assuming you
have these other like assessment parameters that we don't have in the field.
Um, so I'm with you, I'm with you on that one.
I think, I think there is a case to be made for giving calcium at PEA
arrest and nothing else is working.
Yeah.
Cause I'm like, well, you know, you want to stay away from like being cookie cutter,
right?
Like I heard back in the day, they had like a unconscious cocktail or they, you
know, pushed dextrose and parking and like Simon and, but it just seems like it makes
sense because I mean, we honestly don't have the tool to determine it.
And if there's no hardcore side effects, you know, yeah, for sure.
Yeah.
I think in general, the EMS field is getting away from just like dumping
the drug box into somebody.
Um, there's still a few holdovers like the sodium bi-carb thing.
Um, but in this particular case with the calcium for PEA, like I think there's
likely a use case there, there's not a lot of data collection on it.
Um, you sometimes hear calcium referred to as like the poor man's presser.
Um, because it, you know, you will get a little bit of extra squeeze from the
heart after giving it if they're, if their calcium was low.
So I think that's reasonable.
Sweet.
I mean, I don't really expect calcium to turn them around.
It's like how many rounds of epi in are you going to be before you're
even getting calcium, you know, for sure.
So good on that one.
So the fourth one's kind of a two parter when you were, you kind of answered it
involuntarily, I didn't even know I was really mentioning it earlier.
And I talked to that.
Are you tubing?
Like in your case, are you tubing before you go?
You said you would.
I have always tried to tube in the house to get that knocked off the list and just
get that airway, um, like solidified, but I've never had a case of it, but I just
figured the more you move, the more chance that that tube is going to come out.
And you can imagine how a bunch of firefighters would be moving a patient,
you know, as their frantic.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean, I think it depends on what the situation is.
So like, if you find yourself in a situation where you have to intubate
somebody for like airway or respiratory problem, um, it makes sense to do it.
As long as you, you know, brought all your stuff into the, into the patient's
home or the scene or wherever, don't leave your shit in the truck.
It doesn't do you any good.
As long as you have your stuff there, um, make that scene as controlled as you can
and, and do the procedure.
Now, if it's like a traumatic injury where you need to get that patient to an
OR like it might make sense to use like a superglottic airway or just throwing
an OPA and bag them and like get moving fast.
Uh, so I guess that's the initial determination.
Like if the patient like needs to be in the hospital for whatever's going on,
then then do it on the way or use like an alternative.
But if you can fix the problem, like if you need to address it, then, then I
would recommend taking the time to do it there where you are.
Um, in the case of cardiac arrest, um, I always tended when I was like working on
a truck, tended to like work the code where I found them, um, because you're
not going to do, you're not going to do good CPR on the move.
Um, when I was on the trucks, like we intubated all of our codes.
Like that was just what we did.
I think now there are programs that are, uh, more open to the idea of using
superglottics or bagging or, you know, using other strategies.
Um, and I think that makes sense.
There's definitely a lot of like, um, cultural pushback on that idea.
Like medics don't want to lose the, um, yeah, they don't want to lose the
ability to innovate or, and they don't get to do it that often.
So I can see that too.
Like I was the same way when I was working on the truck.
So, um, yeah, I guess the simple answer to your question is it depends why the
patient needs to get the hospital.
If the hospital is the only thing that can fix them, then just do it on the way.
But if you can fix the problem where you find them, then, then take the
time to do it where they are.
Okay.
Yeah.
And then once you have the problem fixed, like, you know, if it was like
a airway ventilation problem and you fixed it by intubating them, just take
your time moving on like you, you fix the emergency and it like nobody cares.
Well, maybe you have supervisors that care, but in the grand scheme of things,
nobody cares if it takes you 20 minutes to get them from where you find them.
To the truck, as long as you're doing it safely.
Um, so that's kind of where I stand on that one.
Yeah.
I like it.
And then, um, I put that link.
So on our codes, they have us put them on a OPA and a non rebreather until we have
like the Lucas set up until pretty much the first initial hassle is kind of out
the way, and then they always say tube after round, but generally, you know, I
mean, we have, we put a medic and an engine on every single call.
Um, so that's six people on a call, you know, so I usually don't get
two rounds in before, uh, I'm innovating.
Like I'm usually like one round and then we're going to go and innovate.
Cause there's just so many people, you know, everybody kind of knows what
to do so it gets done very quickly.
I didn't know, like I'm still going to have to do it right.
Cause it's the protocols of our place.
But what do you think on the, of like kind of passive, uh, ventilation,
kind of like when it's letting off the chest, it's drawing that air in.
Yeah.
Like obviously dude, right.
But yeah, I know that was like a decent amount of like investigation into
this idea like a while back.
Um, and there were some, uh, programs that were just working codes
without managing the airway.
They would just put a non rebreather on their face and then do compressions only.
Um, I don't think that the data ever like supported it, or if it did, it
wasn't like, it wasn't superior to, you know, managing the airway.
Um, that said, I think like probably objectively, I haven't like dug into
the data on this because I don't like where I work, we don't routinely like
run codes like you do when I'm on service on the ground, but I think probably the
best bet would be just to put in a superglottic airway, um, because it's so fast.
Um, and then you, yeah, then you for sure make sure you, like you ensure
that you can ventilate effectively and oxygenate.
Um, but you also can keep doing compressions.
Um, like there's maybe a use case that like the passive oxygenation isn't quite
as effective, like just the chest recoil and compression isn't drawing enough air.
Um, and then there's on the other end, there's argument that doing an
intubation just takes up too much time.
It takes hands off the chest.
So I think like probably if you dug into the data, like the best case would be
just to use a superglottic.
Um, but again, there's going to be a lot of resistance to that, both like
out of hospital and in a hospital.
Um, but yeah, I would have to look up and see like what the, what the current
state of evidence is on, on that idea.
I haven't seen anything about it in a while.
Four.
Oh, can you hear me?
Oops.
Yeah.
You sit there.
Sweet.
I don't know.
I don't know what was going on my computer.
It's so fours done five.
Let's see.
So
and our protocols, they say you can give a denizen to somebody who's in a, if they're
younger, like if it looks like an SVT population, but they're showing why now,
obviously not like true VTAC like coded, you know, but they're stable.
They're tacky card, and it's wide.
And I get the thought process behind it, right?
Because it might stop it, might slow it down.
And then you can kind of see if there is something in there, but
isn't it really dangerous?
Like let's take WPW for example, you have that Kent bundle.
If you block the AV note, won't you have pretty disastrous results because now
your Kent bundle is making up for 100% of the impulse coming.
Yeah.
So you're, you're right on track.
If you have someone with WPW and they're like in a superventral, superventricular
tachycardia and you give them a denizen, you could put them into VTAC or VFib.
Um, I would have to check and see like what the, what the actual like
incidence of that is, um, that I'm not sure.
I know it's quite rare.
Um, but yeah, that's, that's definitely a concern.
So if you had someone that you like knew had a history of WPW, like if somebody
told you, then I would be like hesitant to use a denizen.
Um, but just routinely, I wouldn't, I wouldn't just never give a denizen
cause I'm worried about putting somebody into VTAC or VFib and the fix of that
would be just to like, make sure you have pads on the patient so that if you do put
them into VTAC or VFib, then you can just shock them out of it.
Um, but yeah, so a simple answer would be like, if you, if you have a confirmed
history of WPW, um, maybe hold off on the denizen.
Um, if you, if you are giving someone a denizen in general, just make sure you're
ready to like cardiovert them or defibrillator afterwards, just in case.
Um, it was, yeah, go ahead.
I was going to say there was a, um, there were two, um, references worth looking up.
One is there's a life in the fast lane article that just came out like a month
or two ago about, um, distinguishing different super different wide complex
tachycardias, um, is focused on like VTAC and SVT.
So I can send you a link to that, but that was like an interesting read in general.
Um, and then there's another one from a few years back by, um, a page called
Canadian EM, and they specifically talk about this case.
Like they have, um, they talked through how they would manage a patient.
She's a, I think a younger female in SVT.
The crew gets ready to, um, give a denizen and then the patient mentions like,
Hey, I actually was told once that I have this thing called WPW.
What's that all about?
And it just like talks through there, like how they would manage that.
And they basically come to the same conclusion that, um, like, I don't
actually remember like specifically what they said in the end, but through their
discussion, they talk about like, if you're going to give a denizen to a patient
like this, just make sure you're ready to make sure you have electricity on hand
pads on the patient's chest, you can get them out of any kind of disreming you put
them into, um, but in general, like you could, you could likely wait.
Right.
So we're giving, um, like if we're following ACLS, we're giving a denizen for
a symptomatic, but stable, um, tachycardia.
So you can use your clinical judgment and be like, you know what?
Like I'm okay to like, to hold off for now and see, see how the patient does.
Also depends on your system.
Like if you're, if you're close to the hospital, um, that's one thing, if you're
going to be like, if you're out here in New Mexico and you're 45 minutes away,
it might be a different story.
Um, but you can also wait.
Like you don't have to decide right away.
I know we like teach ACLS like every, every fork in that algorithm is like an
instantaneous decision, but you can, you can sit on things for some time, uh,
especially in that situation where your patient is stable.
Sweet.
We're not going to use out five is done.
So with six asked about early repolarization, uh, that EKG website, but
like Dr.
Kausho, one of the Mayo Clinic guys, uh, he has a quick little like 10 minute video
on it, he was saying it's linked to sudden cardiac death.
Now he says it's very like obscure and it's not something that was like highly
researched, but just something to be aware of.
I, we got called to a jail and we get there and it's like your typical, oh, I'm
having chest pain or I'm having trouble breathing, but he's like, and he's a
younger male, you know, he's like my age, but he's saying things that are like, and
like, how do you know to say that?
You know, like he's saying, Oh, wakes me up from my sleep and oh, it's crushing
chest pain and oh, dolls like goes to my back and like, I'll start sweating rain.
I'm like, and he's just kind of like very like textbook, you know, and of course
the population, like they're probably going to give you more BS than a normal
population because their freedom is gone.
Right.
But how would you just kind of put him in the group of everybody else?
Cause we did a 12 lead on him.
He had early repolarization and he was like B one through three.
He was elevated, no reciprocal changes.
Like not really nothing else saying, uh, stimmy by any means.
And of course he didn't have a stimmy.
They discharged him later, but do you take, you know, a stimmy, like
take, does it kind of snag on your brain when you see that early repolarization?
Does it make you think of anything?
Are you just kind of like, Oh yeah, really repolarization.
Uh, I guess I, I just make a mental note of it.
Like, I don't think in that situation that you're describing, I would be
like extremely worried, like I wouldn't be, you know, calling like for medical
console or putting pads on the patient's chest or anything like that.
Um, yeah, that's another thing that I would have to like look and see what the
specific incidents of like sudden cardiac death related to earlier
polarization and, you know, in the general population that has it is, um, I
imagine it's quite rare, so I wouldn't, I wouldn't be super worried about it.
Um, but it's always something to keep in mind, I guess.
Sweet.
Six is done.
So I was, I took this airway rodeo class by life flight.
It's like a, it's just kind of like a flight medic group, have them out there,
but it sounds kind of like pretty much what you do, like they're flight medics
and you know, they go around teaching and, uh, they gave us this, they were
talking about lidocaine, uh, using it for head traumas to reduce the ICP.
Right.
And a previous book that I had, um, on em crits, like one of his, uh,
recommended readings, I bought this book and they talked about the same thing
in one of the airway chapters.
So I was wondering like, would you use it?
And, uh, I understand pretreatment drugs take like two to five minutes.
And I feel like in situations where I would be innovating, you're not going
to wait two to five minutes because we don't have RSI.
We don't have DSI.
We don't really have any of that.
Right.
So I don't think most people are doing it anymore that for sure was like standard
practice for a while, or anytime we were doing a RSI, um, we're worried about
traumatic brain injury or head injury.
Um, we would pretreat with lidocaine.
Um, but that, I don't know of any like fight programs, at least in this area
that are still doing that.
Um, but there are still a lot of references that discuss that.
And I imagine it might be different, you know, like everything is changed a little
bit by depending on where you are in the country.
So there may be some spots that are still doing it.
Um, but yeah, we don't, we don't routinely give lidocaine when we're
RSIing somebody with a head injury.
Um, but at one time, at one time we would have.
And yeah, and here, like I, I don't think, I think even when I started flying here,
this is in 2013, I think even then it was like already off our protocols or maybe
it was like shortly thereafter.
So it's been a while that we're not doing it.
Some are in the vicinity of like maybe 10 years or so.
Um, but like with anything in medicine, like things take a long time to change.
Um, and there was like, I think there at one time there was some, some decent
evidence that it did reduce the spike in ICP, um, if you pretreat with lidocaine.
So, um, and like the trade-off is negligible.
Like you're not going to hurt the patient likely.
So it seems okay.
Um, but it's one of those things we're generally trying to get away from just
doing all the interventions and trying to focus on the ones that have like
demonstrable value and focus on doing those ones as well.
Sweet.
Lidos done.
Uh, so eight, the magnesium dose timing, because it seems like I know for airway,
this is not going to be one of your like main attacks really at all.
It's like a third or fourth line, but for torsades in the pre-eclamatic seizures.
Um, this is like the, you know, and torsades are probably going to be running
a code because I haven't heard of anybody with torsades who's, you know, not dead.
But in these instances where magnesium is really like the, the kind of fixer of it,
how quickly are you giving it?
Is it two minutes?
It's like over five minutes.
Cause I know you never slam magnesium.
Like you always have to dilute it.
Correct.
Yeah.
Um, I don't know if I've ever seen a protocol that like advocated
for giving magnesium as a push dose.
Um, other than if you have like a non-perfusing polymorphic
V-TAC and you can give that one as a push dose.
Um, but generally you would dilute it over like five to 10 minutes.
Okay.
Um, and in some, like some situations you do it longer.
So, um, like for, um, like a real bad bronchospasm for asthma attack, if you're
all the way down your algorithm and giving magnesium, you could give
that over like 15 to 20 minutes.
Um, this is something I probably should know like off the top of my head, what
the exact timeline is on all the indications of my magnesium, but I just
looked that up when I need to give it.
Cause it's not, it's not like my first line.
So yeah, I fully support you can always look things up.
Yeah.
Well, and how often is it?
It's like, you know, your average man to give you magnesium.
I feel like it's kind of a niche drug, you know?
Yeah.
I don't think, I don't know if I've ever given it pre-hospitally.
Maybe, I mean, we give it in the hospital type, replace labs all the time,
but that's totally different.
But I don't know if I've ever given it in a emergent situation.
Um, I maybe have given it like an isomatation like once or twice.
Um, I don't know.
I guess back when I thought doing all the things all the way down to the
bottom of the algorithm, like made you cooler.
Um, but yeah, I haven't done that in a very, very long time.
I like your hoodie, by the way.
Thanks dude, my girl.
So I, I initially, and I bought a size too small.
I was like, in my days of like, I need to go to an XL.
So I bought a just normal large and as soon as I get it, I'm like, shit, I am an XL.
They bought me this one in an XL and it's, it's super nice dude.
Nice.
I don't have a hoodie.
I don't have a hoodie yet.
I might have to get one eventually.
Yeah, you're going to have to do at nights.
Like, uh, if we don't take out like our officers or something, you know,
how uniforms kind of like they, they kind of get flexible as the night goes on.
For sure.
Chili or like raining or something.
Cause the ones that gave us for work are real thin and you'll be,
you'll be going down hard if you wear it.
It's a solid option.
I like it.
So, so for us, we have the quarter of a milligram per kilo over 10 minutes.
I've never given it any time we've ever had pain.
I've, I pretty much stick with Fentanyl for everything.
Um, is that like, what are your thoughts on that dose over that amount of time?
Does it, does it work for pain?
Um, so it depends.
Um, like where I work, our dose for pain is like 0.1 to 0.25 makes per kilo.
And we always joke that it's like a homeopathic dose.
Yeah.
But that said, like I have seen it work, um, and it varies a lot by the individual.
Um, so specifically with ketamine, like, um, a lot of our medications are, we're
going to go like go down a rabbit hole here, but a lot of the medications that
we use in general, um, they're metabolized in the liver by your side of,
cytokine P450 system.
Um, and then in that system, there are specific subtypes.
Um, that like affect like how you metabolize drugs, um, ketamine specific
is metabolized by like multiple different, um, different components in that system.
And then each of those different components, like may or may not be an
active metabolite, depending on like where you're looking in the literature.
So specific for ketamine, there's like a lot of variation in like how an
individual responds, because it's not just like one direct pathway, like this
meta, this drug, like it's taken up an active form and gets metabolized into
an inactive form via this distinct route.
And ketamine, it's like a little bit all over the place.
So there's like a couple of different ways it gets metabolized in that overall
system, and then sometimes those different metabolites are active as well.
Um, so basically that's like a long way to say that like ketamine is quite
complicated and that like some people will respond to a super low dose just
based on like how their, how their physiology functions and other people,
like you'll give them that 0.25 per kilo and you won't really notice anything.
Um, but it's highly variable.
Um, the good thing about ketamine though, is like you can, like you can always
give more and like repeat it and there's not really like a upper limit.
Like you might put a patient into like a dissociative state, but like at that
point, giving them more will just like cause it to last longer.
It's not like, so like in that sentence, like a very safe medication.
Um, that is definitely like not, not everyone ascribes to that idea, but like
for me, if I'm not sure if it's like I, I air on the side of giving more
ketamine than, than less within the restraints of my, like, of my protocol.
So I'll give that upper end for pain.
I'll give 0.25 and then I can give it as often as every 10 minutes.
So I'll just like keep repeating it.
Okay.
And also like, if it's for a patient who's like, we use it a lot for, um,
post intubation sedation and I have a higher, I have a different higher dose
for sedation, so I can always just use a higher dose and it covers both pain.
And sedation.
Yeah.
So yeah, we use the one milligram per kilo.
Anytime that we innovate somebody, they just tell it on the, unless it's like
a prolonged downtime or something like that, where they would be in pretty.
Um, and I have given it for that.
I really like it for that.
I mean, I've never had a patient like come to after being innovative, you know,
but the only times I've ever innovated somebody or codes and kind of the area
where we get our codes from is we have an area of the city, like it's pretty bustling.
It's like 40,000 people, but then so much of the population lives in the sticks,
you know, to where you're like, you'll be like 50 to an hour away from
Kansas city and some of the parts of the city.
Yeah.
And in that case, like using ketamine at a higher dose for sedation is like,
it's super good for, you know, while you're in transport, like after you do
your emergent interventions, just keeping the patient sedated in calm wire,
making it away wherever you're going.
Sweet.
That is nine.
10 is a bit more of a discussion.
I'm sure I'll have a question derived from it.
We have this patient and we get there and he just looks like he's going to code.
I mean, sweating, pale, clammy, like telling you he's going to die.
He's like half the time talking to you half the time, like reaching in the sky.
He looked terrible and his vitals were pretty unremarkable except his,
I remember his blood pressure went from 170 on the toilet to when we were
like 10 minutes out, he was like 90 systolic and the whole time, you know,
I put the pads on and everything after 12 lead.
He had a history of MIs history of PEs.
Like, I mean, he had it all.
And so I asked for a report back from the hospital when they got done and
he sent it to our EMS chief and they said that this guy was diagnosed with
severe dehydration and an acute kidney injury.
I was shocked by it.
I mean, I thought for sure, like I was thinking like PE or something that was
like a hardcore hemodynamic hit that he was going down, but then I kind of started
realizing he was outside for, you know, like an hour and so maybe that's where
the sweating came from, except he told us he had been inside like 20 minutes.
It was just a very, it was like my first patient of like, what the hell is going
on and then finding out had nothing aligned with like what I was going down.
You know,
yeah, I guess I have a couple of thoughts on that.
One is that like, there could have been more going on than just
dehydration and acute kidney injury, but like a diagnosis of AKI or acute kidney
injuries, like an objective diagnosis based on lab work in the hospital.
So sometimes, sometimes that is like, when you're not sure what's going on,
you're like, Oh, they have a AKI.
There's, I'm trying to think of like another example of something like that.
I don't know.
I can't think of another one off the top of my head, but it could very well be
that like, that was, that was like the most obvious thing based on like objective
measurable parameters, but that doesn't necessarily mean that like your suspicion
that something else is going on is, is invalid.
Like being, being down on fluids, being super dehydrated is, is dangerous in
and of itself, especially with someone who has like a significant cardiac history.
But that may not be like a, a diagnosable thing.
And that situation, like you would expect that he would have, I don't know,
you might see some evidence of like cardiac stress, like elevated
troponin or EKG changes.
Um, that's not always the case.
Um, so yeah, I wouldn't, I wouldn't discount like your concern that there
was something serious going on.
Um, but at the same time like that, that kidney injury diagnosis is, is
a simple, straightforward thing.
So, um, sometimes, sometimes we tend to gravitate towards that.
Like same thing if you have like a really, really sick patient and you like,
you know, you have like a, an outlying lab value that you tend to focus on.
Uh, so like this patient is septic because their lactate is elevated.
Um, and that's not a great example.
Um, I don't know.
I'll work on that to see if I can think of another, another comparable example.
Example.
Um, but yeah, I wouldn't, I wouldn't discount your concern that something
like potentially very bad could have happened.
Um, just based on that.
Um, but yeah, I mean, also the kidneys are quite important.
So like, if you, I mean, people can die from acute kidney injury, like it,
it can set into motion, a chain of reactions that, um, can be quite catastrophic.
So, um, most of the time when we're seeing it, uh, kidney injury, it's, you
know, something that aligns with this narrative, like, Oh, he was dehydrated.
Maybe he took some incense or something.
And like now his kidneys are hurt and you give him some time and
some fluids and he recovers.
Um, but it can be quite severe.
So.
Can your kidney patients have a problem, um, regulating their blood
pressure because of the renin angiotensin system?
Yeah, for sure.
Is that more of a, something you should expect?
Uh, is that kind of a later?
Yeah, that would be more of a chronic finding.
Um, but yeah, like if you have somebody who's got like, um, chronic
kidney disease or like chronic renal failure, you can, I mean, pretty much
every system in your body is eventually going to be affected.
Um, so you can, yeah, like we have issues maintaining your, your volume
or your fluid status.
Um, you can have anemia as related to chronic kidney disease.
Um, there's actually at the, so you'd like to remember this one, right?
There's cases of people having, um, anemia that lead to, um, ischemic
events because, and then like the root cause goes back to chronic kidney disease.
Um, so yeah, like, I don't know if that answered your question or not.
Oh yeah, no, real well.
One second.
All right.
11.
I've got a, I don't remember if I asked this last time.
I've got our books from before.
Yeah.
I had this one written down as well.
We were talking about, um, like when we normally teach STEMI, if we're looking
at ST changes, we identify like the specific part of the heart that's
affected based on those changes.
Um, and you had asked about if there are specific injury patterns, like
within scarbosa criteria.
Um, and I assume that's what this is related to, but I don't actually, I still
don't have an answer for that, but it seems like you found something.
So I was just like wondering on it.
I mean, it's not like for me, I'm going to do anything different, right?
Like if a patient is having a STEMI and they don't look great, like
they're still getting pads.
I still need a line.
I'm still preparing for them to code.
I guess it's more out of, you know, curiosity, but I would, I would just
wonder, and even if maybe not even the, uh, specific area, like if it can't be
localized, but I wonder if when they do have, when they're fitting this
carboza criteria is the mortality comparative to just your regular STEMI.
I wonder if it's worse.
I see what you're saying.
Yeah.
That, that I don't know.
I mentioned that, um, that EKG blog, Dr.
Smith's EKG blog, I wonder, I'll have to look and see if he's got anything
on that specifically, um, because with any of these scoring tools, there's
like any of the scoring tools, there's some variability in like patients may
tend to have like, they may still fit in the framework of this tool.
Like it may be positive, but like there's some over here on the left and
some over here on the right.
Maybe these like ones over here in this camp might have a scheme.
Yeah.
I'm like, I don't know the left side of the heart and these ones have
like an anterior wall ischemia, but that, yeah, I don't know.
Maybe I should dig into that a bit more and see if I can turn anything up.
Um, I imagine the data is there, but this is also like a fairly, like in
the realm of medicine, like, um, it's a fairly new tool, so it will likely
be quite some time until they get all the nuances figured out.
Um,
and I've noticed some people have like modified versions of the Scarboza, like
life in the fast lane has one on a page on the model.
And I always just use the original one.
I mean, I haven't heard anybody speak negatively of it, you know?
Yeah.
I mean, I think I use the modified one just cause it's, it's newer.
And I assume that that makes it better because I could dig a little
more into details of that.
Um, but I think if you're, if you're making an effort to just look at
Scarboza criteria in general, like if you're a patient with chest pain, you
see a button, a branch block and you like either have it memorized or pulling
out a reference to check it.
Like that's, that's already like above and beyond the average that
the most folks are doing in the field.
Um, so yeah, kudos to you for doing that.
Yeah.
Cause I would hate to have a left bundle and my medic isn't, you know, like,
he's like, Oh, you got a left bundle and just throws it to the side.
You're like, Oh, yeah.
And I mean, realistically, like a lot of times when, when I'm doing this, I do
it on the way, like it's not going to change my interventions initially, but
it's more for curiosity sake or like before I call her port, I'm like, all
right, cool.
I know I had a left bundle sky is like complaining of whatever cardiac symptoms.
I'll just get out, you know, like I have it like I'm a little reference
part of keeping my flight suit.
And I also like to look it up on my, I have like a little PDF saved on my
phone with all these references and I'll just pull it up and, you know, just
take a quick look.
Um, but I've never actually like confirm an occlusion using this
carbozine in the field.
Um, but maybe someday, maybe a good nerd moment.
Oh yeah.
A fan's like once in a lifetime.
Trust you, when you get to show up and the cardiologist is waiting on you right
away, you just bring it up with them.
Gold star for sure.
It'll probably happen to either of us and some medic out there will do it.
Not even much.
Like it wasn't even that cool.
Yeah, probably.
So 12, uh, I think I had seen something on somebody's Instagram or I forgot where
I saw it, but the question kind of came to my mind and then I found a journal on
it talking about how giving dextrose to a code, just because we're just assuming
is really bad practice and really bad for the brain.
And I think it may have been somebody on Instagram posted, uh, saying that you
can't trust capillary, um, like sticks, like you can't trust the measurement on
it and that you need a Venus one during a code.
And then I think it kind of branched into that, or maybe I just looked into it.
Yeah.
So the, I guess going back to like where this pushing dextrose and codes comes from
is it's like listed in one of the Hs and Ts that everyone gets taught.
Um, but the problem with that is like this article that you sent, um, discussed
is that like, if you're hyper glycemic, um, post-rost and then like tens towards
more negative outcomes neurologically.
Um, so yeah, that, that totally jives, um, as far as like using the capillary blood
sugar on a patient in code, like, I guess if your perfusion is not adequate, like
if you're not moving that blood, um, that value is not going to be accurate.
So I guess that checks out as well.
I think in general, I don't know, I don't know if we talked about this.
I know I've had this discussion with other folks, like I think having, I think
having like hypoglycemia on a list of Hs and Ts like predisposes us to this problem.
Like, like the state of being like hypoglycemic is probably not what's
going to cause you to go into a cardiac arrest.
Like I'm not, I'm not saying that like, if your blood sugar gets to zero,
obviously that's, that's a problem.
Um, but it's likely that you, you know, like if you're down in like the
twenties and thirties, yeah, that's low of normal, but that's not causing you to die.
What's causing you to die is that you aspirated each out.
Can you stop breathing and things like that?
Um, so I'm kind of like over the years, like de-emphasize this idea when I'm in
a teaching setting of focusing on like ages and T's just like, without
considering each one individually, because I think it does predispose you to problems.
Um, in our setting, like in the field, like we don't have access to drawing
Venus labs almost always in the pre-hospital setting.
So, um, I guess if you've got a reading like early on in a code, like before
you did, like right as you started doing high quality CPR, like you've got on a
chest and somebody was somebody else was like, Oh, I'm going to check a blood
sugar because you have 10 people on scene.
Maybe before you act on it, just wait.
And like, once you start perfusing for that patient doing compressions, like maybe
check it later in the code.
I don't know if that, like, I don't know if that.
Totally makes sense.
Like, I don't know if there was any data to support that.
Um, but I don't know.
Rationally it makes sense though.
Yeah.
But I wouldn't, yeah, I wouldn't focus on like a hypoglycemic state, like all
those ages and T's, even if you want to like consider them blindly, like they all
come later on after we do the initial, like high quality CPR and like stabilized
things, um, other than like obvious things.
Like, you know, if you had a bleeder, like obvious injury that caused a
new more or something like that.
Um, but yeah, I think it's totally okay to de-emphasize hypoglycemia in managing
cardiac arrest until later.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
I would agree.
And we have these, the IVs that we have, like the, the thing that holds the needle
for us, it's got like a little spot.
You could put like just a normal pin.
Yeah, that's a, that's a fair play.
Push down on it, but still it seems to make more sense to do it
during compressions though, than it, and also.
Yeah, for sure.
During compressions anyway, because we should be on the chest and insane amount.
Yeah.
This shows how long I've been like off an ambulance because we like never have to do
that anymore where you like start your line and then you like check a blood
shirt with the blood from my IV.
Um, but that totally makes sense.
Um, so I guess like if you wanted to do this, like, I don't know, if we're trying
to come up with like a, a good, better, best strategy, like maybe somewhere in the
middle would be like start another line, like later on in the code.
And then from that one, check your blood sugar.
That yeah, maybe that would be like a good middle ground.
Yeah.
So 13, let's see.
So 13, I'm pretty much asking about cardi version and pacing and you know, they,
like when you do ACLS, they tell you like, you know, altered mental status or chest
pain or respiratory problems or, you know, these things fit in the like unstable
category of it, right?
Would you mostly besides like the map or the blood pressure?
I mean, obviously if that's like critically low, like 70s, 60s, like, okay,
we're not giving meds, like we need to shock and shock them now.
Kind of besides that, would you kind of dictate it on, you know, each patient?
Like, yeah.
I mean, if you have like somebody who, I don't know, like they, they tend to have
chest pain, like they're diagnosed with like stable or unstable angina and this
is like a normal thing for them.
Um, I, I do think you have some autonomy like in that stable, unstable to, to make
that determination on your own, regardless of what like the actual algorithm says.
Um, the algorithm, I like to think of that as like, it exists for when you're not
sure what to do, right?
It's there as like a fallback.
Like, if you're like, ah, like what do I do?
I can't, I can't figure out what's going on.
Okay.
My patient fits into this box and here's the treatment.
Um, but there's always going to be like some gray areas there.
Um, so yeah, I'm, I'm with you on that one.
Then like, if, even if your patient has chest pain, um, but they look, they
look fine to you, they look stable.
Um, I think that's totally reasonable.
Yeah, I would be there.
Uh, and, uh, okay.
So I had a buddy of mine.
Uh, he's been a medic since like 2008 or something.
He's, he's getting up there in age.
And, uh, he was telling me at one of his other jobs, he tubed a patient that
still had like, he doesn't have RSI at this place.
He said it was a stroke and respirations were terrible, super shallow, super low.
And he said that he bagged the lady and then innovated her and was saying
that she had like a gag reflex, but it, the way he made it sound was like.
She had a gag reflex, but it wasn't like intense enough to aspirate or any of that.
Doesn't that seem, is that normal or cause the only times I've ever
intubated is code and like, obviously that's pretty easy innovation.
So you can like, depending on like how, like if you tried to just intubate
somebody with an intact gag reflex, who's like at their baseline, you probably
wouldn't be able to pass it to because their gag reflex is going to be
strong enough that you like, it just won't work, um, or, but there is like, it
does exist on a scale.
So like as a patient, like goes from like normal human towards like big
and unconscious, like that reflex will deteriorate.
It's not like an on and off switch.
Um, so yeah, you, you can see that where you have somebody who's like kind of like
declining on that spectrum or like, you know, swirling the drain as everyone
likes to say, um, where you could intubate them, even though they have
like a weak Agra reflex and you can, you can still intubate them.
You see this more often in, in kids, in particular with like babies, like, um,
most everywhere now, like in the pre-hospital realm is like moving towards
like, if the patient has a pulse, we're giving drugs.
Like we're doing some kind of like pharmacology to mitigate pain and to
sedate the patient before we pass a tube.
But, um, it's not uncommon to for like in a, in a NICU or for like an
inelasticity cessation for like babies to be intubated without any medications.
Um, and if they do have a guy reflexes just cause it's not strong enough to
like, to stop the procedure.
Um, but generally with adults, we don't see that too often.
Um, I guess this makes me think of like when, when I was working on the trucks
where I worked, we didn't have RSI either.
And we would use, um, we were allowed to nasally intubate.
And I guess that was the same thing because you had patients who were like
somewhere in the middle, they weren't like totally unresponsive.
It wasn't like a crash airway, but they like had some and yeah, you could just
push past through it sometimes.
And sometimes you couldn't, but, um, yeah.
So I guess the short answer would be like, it all like lives on a spectrum.
So there is a case where you could intubate someone with the intact gag
reflect, just cause it's not that strong.
I like it.
Yeah.
You know, working on an ambulance made me realize how much they don't teach you in
school just because, you know, there's not enough time to, yeah, for sure.
Yeah.
I mean, I think that conversation comes up quite a lot, like in the EMS community,
especially like folks doing education, like, oh, like, I wish I would have known
this in an EMT school or in that ex-school, but like, realistically, you got like a
lot of shit to learn already.
Yeah.
Um, like this kind of stuff.
I don't know.
I think it's good to know, but I don't know how valuable it is to, to focus on
during your initial training.
Like the whole goal of a training program is to make you like a competent
entry level provider, um, with the expectation that you're going to like
keep on learning afterwards.
Um, but yeah, I think there's an ongoing struggle for everyone who like
manages the EMS training program.
They're like, I want to teach all these things.
Um, but I've only got so many hours and so much time in the classroom.
Um, and a certain plane, like if you, if you're, you know, pushing too much
information on something that I can retain it anyways.
And that's what I was going to say.
Sometimes things can be very confusing if you don't know like the basics of it.
You know, for sure.
Yeah.
I mean, like, for example, I had been a medic for probably like five or six
years before it finally, before I finally had it committed to memory, like.
Which vessels perfused which parts of the heart?
Like when I was looking at a UKG, like I knew my, like, I knew the side of the
heart, right?
Because we learned that in medic school, but it took a long time for me to like
make the connection to like, okay, like this piece of the heart is
perfused by this vessel.
Um, and that was me, like every once in a blue moon, like hitting the books again.
And like, it took a long time before it finally clicked.
Um, I think that happens a lot.
Uh, yeah.
No, I like that very specific, like the left main coronary left anterior
descending, like I, I like that because it's kind of like now, you know, why
some heart attacks are more feared than others, you know, like I really, for sure.
Well, the vessel is absolutely massive.
And it helped me a lot with, uh, like the, you know, they always say if they have a
right sided heart attack, like stay away from the eye trail, but they're right
sided and inferior, you're basically all from the RCA unless you're at like 10%
where you're not, but I always liked that.
And it helped me understand, um, EKG is a little more too, you know, now granted.
Have I been in a situation where I'm like, Oh, thank God I knew an artery.
No, but
right.
It's definitely a icing on the cake kind of thing.
Yeah, exactly.
Plus it's just fun.
You know, it's just fun to know things about the body.
I'm with you on that.
So, well, that's all the real ones.
I got one.
So I'm starting up a cardiology.
I've got to tutor these kids and this kind of goes with what we were just
talking about the not feeding them too much information.
Do you think I should use it more as like a Q and a, cause they're already
getting their, they are already getting their like
like main learning done with their professor.
Correct.
So by the time that he wouldn't you think that they would have questions of their
own and know what they don't understand or
Yeah, ideally, um, I think like when you first learn something though, it takes a
while for you to like see whatever it is you're learning in practice and like to
have questions.
So like they may not come to you with questions or like maybe have a couple of
things that you can like review with them.
One of the things I think helps a lot is, um, like drawing out, like drawing out
things.
So, um, like for me, what I'll do is like, have people draw like just an EKG strip.
Like, what does this hump look like?
And then like, what is the, like, what does the P wave actually look like in lead
to what does your QRS normally look like?
Um, cause a lot of times we just like draw a squiggly line, but you're like,
wait a second, like in lead to it actually goes this direction first.
Uh, it goes up first.
If you see go down, like this is what this would be a problem.
You know, like you can talk through those things and get them to like actually draw
the specific details.
Um, and then you can also like look at their, like, like their sizing.
Like, let's say they like drew, like, I'm going to draw it across the screen here.
If they drew a hump and then they do their QRS and then like right after it, they put
a T wave, you're like, well, like normally like there's some space here, right?
And normally like your P wave is like pretty close to your QRS and you can just
like reinforce that like the first step in all this is just like looking for what's
normal.
Um, it's like a good, good place to start.
And then when you get to like more advanced things, like I, like if we're
talking about like drawing the vessels and like which vessel perfuses, which
part of the heart, like I normally would just like draw actual heart, like draw
my heart is like a heart shape, like you see on the Valentine's.
And then from there, like just sketch out like the vessels, like you from just like
right of the crease in the middle is where you have your like, um, uh, like your
left main coming down and it splits off to the left and then, um, to your
circumflex and then your right corner goes around the back and you can kind of
like, just draw that in a simple sketch.
Um, and those are like, just like simple activities to just reinforce those ideas.
Um, like I wish I had like been more into like, like when I was, when I was in
med school and like for most of my life learning in school, I was always just
like reading the books, just like reading things over and over.
Um, but I think that's like a pretty time intensive way to learn things.
Like it works, right?
Like I made it here.
Um, but I think there are better ways to, to get those concepts like drilled into
your brain.
And I, I've come around to the idea that like making things like drawing pictures
and like creating content, like putting things together, like really helps me.
Um, so I don't know if that's useful for you or not, but
very useful because it's in a box of crayons.
Yeah.
Oh, I got the expo markers lined up and ready to go.
They've got this big fancy, like, uh, kind of like a study hall at the school,
which is shocking because it's a community college and not a very good
part of the city, but boy, did they pour money on it.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
Besides that, that's, that's all I got for you.
I try not to have anything that was like crazy and I tried to keep everything at
least somewhat pertainable to like my everyday job, you know?
Yeah, no worries.
Um, those are good questions.
And there's also like, I mean, some of the stuff like I got your list the other day
and I had to go through it and I should probably know this off the top of my head,
but let me like look into this a little bit.
So I mean, this is why we do it as well.
Right?
It's not, it's not just us spouting things.
We already know it's also a learning opportunity for us.
I had that on the first one number, the very first time that we met, you told me,
don't worry about the one milligram.
The one to two milligrams of her said for like your CPAP patients that are really
fighting it, I gave this guy one and it chilled and it kept him from being
innovative.
It was bad.
Yeah.
That's sweet.
You know, I kept looking up at him.
I'm looking at him.
He didn't stop breathing on you, huh?
He did not stop breathing on me.
It was, but I did have that one doctor tell me, well, she's in a nurse crack.
I come to find out and get the one going to knock out this patient's respiratory
drive because I put him on CPAP.
Not that guy, but somebody like, uh, yeah, it was that day I texted you and I'm
over here like, Oh, this is a great call.
I had terrible, good IV, I had to use like baby IVs on him.
It was just a great call.
And we got like 40 minutes of work because you're coming from the sticks.
And when she said it, I was like looking around and nobody else here in the
shit right now, like, uh, kind of like the main doc of the hospital or the ER.
And he was like, he didn't, I didn't say a name, but he knew exactly who told me
that I didn't know that he does the scheduling.
And so he knows exactly who was there when, but he was like, yeah, he was like, you
should just ignore that.
He's like, don't let anybody, you know, on somebody sounds good.
Yeah.
I mean, I think that's in general, good advice.
Like whenever you hear something like that and like, yeah, like, like I'm not sure
if that's true, like always get a second opinion.
Yeah.
I mean, any, a mess we're prone to, to making like statements of authority
based on like cases of one, or just, yeah, it's a good thing to keep in mind.
Yeah.
She's nice.
I mean, she's a nice person.
Don't get me wrong, but boy, not a good way to start out.
That was like the second or third time ever met her to you.
I kind of hated her for like a month, but then I was like, yeah.
You got to get past that.
Well, dude, if you're good, I'm good, man.
Sweet, man.
Well, um, yeah, that was good stuff.
And, um, I'll text you in my email.
Would you mind sending me those?
Actually you have my email.
Will you send those articles?
Yeah, for sure.
Yeah.
And I think eventually I'll put this together into like a video, um, like put
it up on the YouTube channel and I'll put links in that video as well.
So other folks can, can nerd out with us.
I think that'd be rad.
Yeah, I mean, you're going to be famous one day.
I doubt that.
Right on, dude.
Well, take care and, uh, yeah, let me know next time you get a page of notes,
a page of questions, and we'll do it again.
Sounds good, man.
Uh, if you're okay with it, some like a month-ish for now.
Yeah, for sure.
Anytime, dude.
Sweet.
Thank you, man.
Yeah.
Take care.